raising money is a form of going into
debt
you can either get a loan which you're
not going to get when you're a startup
or you can go say i'll give you 40 of my
company 30
of my company for 28 million dollars for
round one you know hey
we'll do 10 million you know you know
this stuff you you you've read about
this you're familiar with this
so if you don't raise the money you
can't
accelerate hiring technology office
space advancement
partnerships you just can't make the
product as
good as you could because you have to
make everything cheaper
so i look i sit there and i i see the
negative aspects of
purchasing power 97 which means a dollar
is now worth three cents but that's
because of
inflation which they fully have control
over
and i fully see that as a big problem i
mean you heard powell yesterday say the
fact that they're not
going to raise the rates until 2023
until inflation goes back to two percent
but to say advancement would be at the
same level i would really want you to
dissect that a little bit more maybe i'm
not getting it because
i don't see how advancement would be at
the same level if we were in lending
well the assumption there is that we are
not lending i'm not talking about that
i think i think lending is a very
important part
uh of financing capital projects
and productive projects i'm not talking
about getting rid of loans or anything
like
that i'm talking about making the loans
realistic and not so easy
so that people are more cautious with
the loans so we don't have the busts and
the
and the destroyed business ventures
quite so often so we look at the
business ventures that succeed
this is wonderful but then we we forget
all about those
little companies that never succeeded
collapsed because they shouldn't have
been loaned they should have gotten the
money in the first place
they were under financed i think the
best i guess the best example of that is
the
the housing bubble the real estate
bubble that we've
lived through it a couple of times we're
living through it now again the second
time
no question you could go and you could
buy a house didn't make any difference
whether you were employed or not
made no difference how much money you
earned made no difference
at how expensive you didn't have to
prove that you could pay
for that house you could just go borrow
the money and the banks knew that
when the loan finally soured
that they'd get bailed out by the
federal government so they didn't care
whether you
whether it was a good loan or not
because they were going to make their
money one way
or the other and that's what i'm talking
about if if there were a real honest
system and then the loans wouldn't be so
big and so easy
but they would still be there and they
would be more they'd be
restricted to the ventures that have the
highest possibility of
of succeeding and we get all of the
failures out of that picture
and and and you get a reduced uh
let's say a portfolio of all the
succeeding companies but you've also got
a huge
reduction in the failure companies as
well
you put them together my my solid
conviction is
that the growth would be slower but it
would be more even and we would get rid
of the booms and the busts
and the end result would be better than
what we actually have seen
i think of the book by written by henry
haslet
one of the original books that got me
thinking as a as a
free-market type of a person years ago
henry has wrote a book
called economics in one lesson i urge
everybody to read that book
and when i first saw the title of that i
thought this is absurd how can there be
one lesson
for something like economics which is so
diverse
so i bought the book and by the time i
got to page seven i said by golly he did
it he got it into one lesson
so i'd like to paraphrase that lesson
for you because we're talking about that
now
as let's said and get this right
when analyzing the merits or the
demerits of any economic proposal
we must not consider just
the effect of it on one person or group
of people
for a short period of time
but we should look at the effect on all
groups
of people and all individuals over a
long period of time and that is
it when you you just look at the good
things that happen and forget the bad
things
for example you look at here's somebody
that deserves to be helped
but you don't think about all the people
that don't deserve
to have the money taken out of their
pockets so that you can help this one
person
maybe you put those people into poverty
you know if you put
if you look at all aspects of the
equation over a long period of time
it's a whole different story i think
that
lesson of economics applies to what
we're talking about